bunions get nasty with it hi I'm Dez I'm
from Australia hi I'm Joyce and I'm from
the United States and we're swapping
chips
I can't wait to educate you in the pure
fine cuisine of the American champ
[Music]
so bugles these are not only great for
eating they're good fun
likewise rumor that this is like a
playground you just publish Acme
playground even though most college
students going through their first
breakup it is it's so nice
have you ever had it before not a bit
like I think I know what you might know
of this there you know where we're going
with this this is a tree how they good
yeah they're okay
I don't know gonna be better just like
gonna be bigger so you can put them on
your finger you're just making it harder
to breathe see these and cheezles
I'd say they like it cheater but like
mom much like bugles um chisels are a
lot of fun they're like a ring so you
can put them around like exactly and
then you can eat them off your fingers
and these taste really good as well like
I was a big fan of changeless growing up
he's a great oh yeah that's fine Oh
hopefully we can I have a legitimate
like Instagram picture with these you
know I'm saying like a bunch of rings
everything here this is one
[Music]
yeah I'm so excited for you to try this
so Vega um Red Rock deli chips potato
chips
um so this is sweet chili and sour cream
and these are kind of like a gourmet
chips are they're more expensive than
your average sour and they're so good so
you have blue cheese please
so if you have like an extra three
dollars in your wallet like this is
where it's at
when these are on special the nation
stops see that piece in the back that's
the kind of piece you want the double
yeah like you want double the crunch Wow
you know you open a bag and you point
this one there we go oh yeah that's very
good right Wow
that's a good firm hardship it's sweet
but it's a little spicy you know like my
being honest ready you know like we're
just she has money or credit scores up
okay so let me show you good American
trash that is the Dorito and the best
flavor its Cool Ranch especially when
you haven't left your house in three
days playing video games and your mom's
telling you the dog sighs this is
classic when you go to Doritos you got a
red bag you've got a blue bag yeah we
have torito's as well but I don't think
Cool Ranch exists we haven't Arita it's
just not that playful yeah that's kind
of a subtle play though yeah so which is
why it's my favorite because finally
need the red ones and yes yeah so we're
coming back for another American
classics flamin hot cheetos these are
either going out of history and they're
so iconic that they saw me to foods I
did have burritos and yeah
they're that good that there's eight
cards away looks like let's just throw
them on whatever
these are gonna have your fingers so red
oh you have the red that you're gonna
see like there's a lot of never seen red
ones before these these are flaming huh
all right okay these are prepared to
measure inside the my brother I think
they're weird
you definitely video here um they're
really spicy just like these students
really cool this is Chester Tito you
bake away my cousin is everybody's
cousin he's your guns I've got twisties
this is like the original the cheese
flavor and I feel like this is like
stepsister really unpopular little
cousin it like there's something off
about the chicken and every time like
people prefer the chicken was I find it
so weird I'm a big fan of the chicken
Mons what I do know is that when I first
open it up man a snow came out
immediately it's like a Cheeto but
they've like made sure they put C's on
every piece of the outside of it I don't
even want to try these bottles like
they're like not related you know what I
mean they like feuding that one tastes
like soup and that tastes like the
cheese you put on your popcorn it
doesn't taste like chicken it's like a
if they had anything called chicken
seasoning that's right okay so these are
burger rings and I personally hate them
that's pretty good yeah absolutely
I was a dime's what I was gonna get
I want you to exam oh yes I'm so excited
as well I am having this young young yes
I need a partner when he can have fun
then maybe these are meant to be like a
boot up you make the burger patty oh you
know they look it perfectly fits in
there let's talk let's go with our love
no you have cheetah it's right love
Cheetos
so these are cheese and bacon balls
she's a bacon and they're like so
addictive I've never heard of a cheese
and bacon ship in America before but it
would not surprise me they're out there
somewhere let's be honest if you ate a
bag of Cheetos like puffy Cheetos and
then you like your mom made breakfast
and you ate it that's what it tastes
like it tastes like bacon grease and
cheeto all right so these are talkies
Poppy's classic I've never had talked to
you before I'm gonna be honest with you
but I heard Justin Bieber reason so try
I'm like nervous
[Music]
goodbye little oh okay I mean if you
want to be 30 you can
[Music]
that's pretty light another bring its
allies yeah all right that is a by far
the worst cheap I've ever eaten in my
life I hate it no they taste like soy
sauce oh yeah I don't mind those
I think they were very exciting like
they're just terrible
the spicy options are like it's a bit
too like punishing I think like I want
to like be able to enjoy this is not
active era do you know a man like I
don't know how to like come up for air
no no I'm not I'm not gonna take any
hair I don't know oh my god yeah no true
the fun yeah yeah
[Music]